welcome to the future of farming the
Agri drone sprayer revolutionizing
agriculture this Tech Marvel is a game
changer these flying machines are not
your average drones they're programmed
to spray pesticides and fertilizers on
crops ensuring every inch of the field
is covered with pinpoint accuracy they
reduce waste and increase efficiency a
win-win for farmers and the environment
no terrain is too tough no field too
vast the aggri Drone sprayer is a true
example of modern farming at its best
forget traditional methods this is the
dawn of agretech from Patty fields to
corn mazes the Agri drone sprayer is
setting new standards in agriculture
Join the Revolution embrace the future
with Agri drone sprayer remember
technology is only as good as the change
it brings and this is a change for the
better hash agriculture hash AGR drone #
agch # drone # modern farming # Patty #
spray